[موسيقى]
كان في كان في نوع من الانظمه استولت على
المنطقه منذ عبد الناصر نعم وهي الانظمه
اخذت الناس فوتتهم
بتهليز معتم رهيب
ما له افق الا يهزم يا نكبي يا مصيبه يعني
ما له افق
عقلينه لانه اي محاوله خروج عقلاني من
المازق للزعيم بحط البلد فيه
بتؤدي لاولا لشقوط سلطته وسقوط مبررات
السياسيه والفكريه لسلطته وفي انهيار ينتج
حروب اهليه طبعا طبعا
[موسيقى]
هذا النظام بخاف من كل شيء بخاف من كل شيء
لشعور عميق بانه هو مو شرعي مغتصب سلطه
الشعب ومغتصب الشعب
فهذا النظام بيعمل الناس
اولا بصدقوا الاشاعات لانه ما بيعرفوا
الوشيه بالثقافه العامه
بيسود خوف الناس من بعض قله ثقتها ببعض
في كتاب كتير حلو
لامريكيه اسمها
عن سوريا اسمه
غموضات اذا بجوز نجمع غموض غموضات السيطره
تحكي كيف انه مثل ما بتذكر بعدي كيف انه
الكلام بين السوريين يا محافظه الاسد صار
قايم على فكره كما لو ان يعني بنحكي بنقول
مثلا حافظ الاسد بطل تحرير فلسطين كلنا
بنعرف انه هذا الحكي كذب بس كلنا بنتصرف
كانه صح كما لو انه مضبوط
[موسيقى]